each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi everyone I'm Jeanne young and today
I'm going to be talking about how to
make it easier for the programmer to
enforce privacy policies and things like
social networks as Andre said and so we
all agree by now that privacy matters
people are putting more and more data
online and programmers have to deal with
all that and also people often get it
wrong so even Facebook with privacy
being so core to their model and with
all their developer resources has a leak
every now and then as we see an example
here and it's not surprising that
developers get it wrong because there
are many possible points of failure so
let's consider what happens when we want
to enforce the simple policy that only
my friends can see my GPS location well
to enforce this policy we have to go all
through the implementation and enforce
it not just where we're looking at the
location but also where we are finding
all users at a specific location or
finding the most popular locations and
what's worse is that the policies are
getting more and more complicated we can
have a policy that not just my friends
can see my GPS location but my friends
who are nearby can see my GPS location
in the next five hours and so now the
programmer has to keep this in mind all
across the program and some people might
say while this is just a developer
education problem if we just taught
developers how to do it right everything
would be good I argue that it the
problem isn't that developers don't know
how to enforce these policies it's that
they have to do it over and over again
across the program and if there's one
thing we know in software engineering
it's that asking developers to do the
same thing over and over again is error
prone and so let's think a little bit
about how to fix this problem if we
could just worry about the policy
without worrying that anything else it
actually isn't so complicated right
if we could think about the rest of the
implementation without worrying about
the policies that is much simpler as
well and if we separated the two what we
would need then is a way to put them
back together and still produce the
right results and I'd like to point out
that to do this we need to be able to
track information flow because we're not
just looking at the locations but we're
also looking at where they're flowing
and so what we want is a tighter
coupling with the language semantics in
order to automatically handle these
policies so in this talk I will be
describing Jeeves a programming language
for automatically enforcing these
policies and the key idea behind Jeeves
is that you have multiple views of
sensitive values and you rely on the run
time to automatically use the right view
and so for my location I can declare two
different versions of it I can have my
actual gps location and then I can have
some other version of it that's more
keeps me more private like my country
that I'm currently in or something like
that and then the programmer can
associate policies to protect my
location and this location can flow into
the core program as any other value and
so we can find all users that are
currently at Microsoft Research
Cambridge over these locations without
knowing what the policies on the
locations are and then the runtime
becomes responsible for showing the
right output given the user so Andre who
is my friend and also near me right now
might be able to see that buyer and I
are here for the next five hours and
then my group mate rishabh who's not
here and maybe is not even my friend
sees only that I have no friends in this
location right now and so let's look a
little bit about at what this looks like
in a program and so what we have is we
can introduce labels the get associated
with sensitive values and sensitive
values have a high confidentiality
component
a low confidentiality component and the
label guarding which one gets used and
which label up the value of the label
can take on either high or low depending
on policies that are introduced with
label and so here we have a policy on
label a that has a label and takes a
function of an output channel and a
predicate describing when the label a is
allowed to be high and then the program
can now use this location value as any
other program value and the runtime is
responsible for producing the right
output given the output channel so Andre
when the message is printed to him
should see my actual gps coordinates or
something like that whereas rishabh
should just see you that I'm in the
United Kingdom and so how the geebs
runtime executes is we perform what we
call faceted execution and so the
sensitive values are what we call
faceted values they have a high
component a low component and a label
and every operator can now deal with a
faceted value along with a regular value
and how it does this is it looks at each
component of the facet execute on each
of the facets and then puts the result
back together with the appropriate label
and in this way we can also handle
implicit flows because when we have a
conditional executing on a faceted
condition we execute both branches and
then we put the results back together
and alongside this execution the runtime
stores policies by mapping labels to
these functions and then when it's time
to output the runtime produces a system
of constraints by applying the policies
to the output channel and the runtime
uses this to provide an assignment to
the labels and then uses this assignment
to figure out what's the appropriate
value to project out in print
and so let's take a closer look at the
policies to better understand what's
going on there and so here we have a
policy that for label a we have the
function that if the output channel is
near me then a is allowed to be high
right and how this is handled is that it
gets translated to this function that
adds a constraint if the output channel
is not near me then a has to be low and
so there are a couple things to note
here first of all the policies might
refer to sensitive values and because
here my location might actually be
sensitive and so we have this
interesting thing going on that if the
output channel is near the sensitive
location then the sensitive location can
be revealed the other thing to note here
is that all the policies take the form
of restricting labels too low and so
what we have is that first of all we
should observe that we always have a
consistent assignment if we assign the
labels too low if we assign all the
labels slow it's always consistent and
for this reason we also have this notion
of maximal functionality which means
that if we can assign something too high
we will try to assign it to high unless
it conflicts with other assignments and
that way we don't just show the lowest
confidentiality outputs to all users at
all times
and so now you might be wondering okay
what does this mean more formally and
before we get into that let's talk about
what you might be expecting so in
classical information flow we have this
notion of lattices we have a lattice of
access levels and so if you have a
higher axles level you get access to
more privileged information so level one
is Andre and Byron you know their
employees they get to know some stuff
that everybody else in the world does it
at a higher level is you know maybe you
have to have founded the company to to
know what's going on and then at the
highest level well if you live in the
u.s. it's the NSA they know everything
that other people don't seem to know and
the the property that people care about
in programs like this is that if you is
that outputs are revealed at the right
level right so let's say we have a piece
of classified information at level 3
only the NSA can see it and we try to
combine it with this andy warhol
painting which everyone can see the
result is this andy warhol de Graaff
that's at level 3 right and we want to
make sure that only the NSA can see it
and so this is what people tend to care
about with these classical information
flow properties right we have
information it's flowing we want to make
sure only the right people can see it
Jeeves is a little bit different because
you always get some result right the
thing is you have different versions of
values flowing to the user and depending
on what their level of access is they
get to see a different version of it and
so now we have to define this low
confidentiality component for our graph
and we have to associate it with some
policy saying hey like only the NSA can
see this graph right and now in jeans
when we combine it with this andy warhol
painting for the NSA they get to see
this really lovely Andy Warhol graph and
then everybody else gets to see this
equally lovely Andy Warhol access denied
right so I'm so are our non-interference
theorem takes into account the fact that
we have this high component in the slow
component and what we say is that if we
have a sensitive value with a hike
component h and a low component l given
a fixed value of l and a label a all
executions where a must be low produce
equivalent values no matter what the
output no matter what the value of HS
and there's a subtle thing here that
takes well not here but in our actual
theorem that takes into account the fact
that the value of the label a might
actually depend on the value of H as we
saw with if you have a policy that
depends on the distance or something
else sensitive and I'll explain in more
detail in the next couple of slides what
this means and so let's think back to
our policy of is near me and suppose it
gets expanded out to something that says
that restrict a given the output channel
if the distance between the output
channel in my current location is less
than 25 units then a is allowed to be
high right and so there's a case where
we have the protected location and the
viewer within 25 units of the protected
location and in this case a is allowed
to be high and this information is
allowed to leak right there's also the
case where the viewer is outside the
radius of the protected location right
and we're already leaking a little bit
of information that hey you're outside
the protected location and that's why
you couldn't see the information but
what the viewer is not allowed to see is
which of these locations outside the
radius that the protected location
actually is and so what what on our
non-interference theorem says is that
the high value is not flowing out to the
viewer in this way so that if if it's
allowing the label to be high than it
does flow if it doesn't allow the label
to be high then you don't know which of
those values in that space it was
and so we've been taking this and we've
been playing around with this and the
actual I in actual implementations to
make sure that you know code actually
does look better this way and it makes
sense to program this way and I'm we
have a couple of implementations right
now one is in Scala and one is in Python
I'll talk about some of the more details
of this and I'll see why we have to in a
little bit but the main idea behind the
implementations is that we overload
operators to perform the faceted
evaluation so all you really need to do
to embed this in a language is you take
all your operators you define what it
means to do faceted evaluation on that
and you also have to keep track of a
runtime environment that map's labels to
policies and then what we do for
effectual computations like print is we
used III to help us find a satisfying
assignment to all the labels that's
consistent with the policies and then we
use this assignment to project out the
value to print and we started with our
Scala implementation first and we did a
case study where we built a conference
management system that was briefly
powering the pldi 2012 student research
competition but then we stopped for some
reasons I can talk about later um and
and what we what we built was the system
where you have your policies and then
you have your core functionality and the
same code is showing different different
pages to different users for instance
the reviewer and the authors and what
the what the architecture of the system
looks like is we had classes for
defining the data types like the papers
the reviews and the users and the fields
and those classes had the policies
associated for instance all the people
who are part of reviewing the paper I
can see the titles the authors cannot
see the reviewer identities and so on
and so forth and the context that we're
using the the value that gets passed to
the functions has not just who's looking
at it but also the stage look on the
conference for instance the submission
stay
page or the review or the rebuttal or
the decision stage or even the public
stage where everyone can see all have
the accepted papers and on the core
program then all that has to do is
display papers search over papers add
and remove tags and a sign and submit
reviews and so now the core program can
be extended arbitrarily without having
to worry about the policies and if the
if the PC chair decides hey we're not
doing double blind anymore we're doing
single blind all he or she has to do is
tweak code or tweak some options that
changes code in the in the data classes
and so I if you're interested in looking
at lines of code in our system we use
the schol Lara system for our front-end
and we used a squirrel interface to a
sequel database for a back-end we had
almost three thousand lines of code 128
lines of which was policy code and by
calls the policy code I mean code that
calls make label or make sensitive or
restrict for the policies and the cool
things here note are that all the policy
code is isolated in the data classes and
also that the policy lines of code are
less than five percent of the entire
code and if we chose to extend our
conference management system we would
just be extending the functionality down
here most likely and so this was built
using our Scala web framework and so we
had our embedded domain-specific
language and Scala we use schol atra for
the front end and we had squirrel for
the back end um from these lessons uh we
decided to build a Python web framework
for a couple of reasons one was that I'm
the the web frameworks for Python are a
little bit more mature and also there
are some other reasons like there are a
lot more undergrads who are willing to
build web apps and Python and that sort
of thing but but also Python there's
some more other fun things about
python that i can talk about if you're
if you're interested but um but we're
currently working on this python
implementation that um that is three
quarters done and so our goal is really
to show that something like Jeeves can
be used in a web framework where you're
displaying different versions of data to
different users and towards us towards
this goal we're looking at a couple of
other things and so the first of which
is thinking about inputs as well as
outputs so so far I've talked about a
system in which we have policies that
allow the program to select which
outputs get shown to which users right
but what about writes into the system
and so the faceted machinery is actually
pretty nice for putting policies on
showing different versions of rights to
different users so here if we have
reviewers writing new reviews into the
system it's really easy to create facets
so that we're showing nothing to the
author but something to the reviewer and
also because facets allow you to soar
different versions of data you can also
imagine a case where in the decision
phase or the rebuttal phase you're
you're freezing the version of the
review that you're showing to the author
but you're showing all the updates to
another reviewer and what gets even more
interesting is that if you have a system
of reviews not just for a conference
management system but something like
Yelp and you have different kinds of
users showing different kinds of reviews
and scores to other users and you can
actually have a system where the viewers
can specify what kinds of inputs they
would allow to flow to them and you can
have policies that talk about both
inputs and outputs so that you can have
these selective views based not just on
who's looking at it but who wrote
different values as well so we've been
working on this mechanism for a little
while and we've implemented it and it's
based on attaching policies to the
mutable state so the inputs of the
system are associated with rights to the
mutable state we have policies
that are associated with mutable
reference cells and what these policies
look like is they are 22 argument
functions that take now an input channel
and an output channel and talk about
both in terms of who can see what so you
can say if the input channel is friends
with Ellis then the value can flow to
the output and you can also say
something like if the input channel is
Alice and the output channel is friends
with Ellis then this flow can occur and
there's some so there's some interesting
things that happen but we essentially
have this guarantee as we had before
that you have different versions of a
system executing based on each new right
essentially and you have a separation of
the different versions and we've been
looking at a couple of case studies with
with these new right policies so we have
a basic authentication example we
extended our conference management
example and we also built this little
battle slipped game where you have to
users and they each have board where you
can put down ships and the locations of
the ships are not revealed until you
bomb the ship or the game is over and
what we found is that these right
policies are pretty useful for so they
essentially subsume cabinet reality and
integrity policies you can you can
express all those policies that way and
also you have this nice separation of
policy and other functionality that
allows you to play with some other
things for instance in the battleship
game you can encode all of your game
rules as policies so for instance I can
see your your ship if I bomb if both of
us have put down our pieces I've bombed
your ship and or the game is over right
and the functionality then becomes this
is how you show the board this is how
you put down a ship this is how you put
down a bomb and this is how you make a
move and so there are some interesting
programming paradigm ideas to think
about with that as well and another
thing to note is that
these policies talk not just about the
principles that are making each move but
also aspects of the game state right so
this is what the board looks like and so
so we found that to be pretty
interesting as well and so towards
building a web framework the final part
of this is the interface with the
database and so the thing that we notice
from building our web applications was
that in order to not break our
guarantees when interacting when
interacting with the database we
essentially can only do select star from
various tables right and if we really
want it to be safe we would randomize
the order of that as well but if we
wanted to build an application that
scales and we want to have something
that takes advantage of database
optimizations we'd really like to be a
little right select star from authors
were from papers where the author is
Jean young or something like that but
you can imagine a case where in my
runtime I have a policy that says that
you can only know the author and these
certain cases but then with a query like
this that can be revealed through search
or something you can easily subvert
those guarantees right so what what we
would like to do is for the database to
have a notion of this high and low
values and also the policies so that we
can more optimally return the
appropriate faceted values from the
database without returning the entire
database back into the runtime memory
and so we've been we've been looking at
some ideas for how we can represent this
in the database how how we can optimize
queries or how we can wrap around the
database to make more optimal queries
and that sort of thing and so once we
have all these pieces down we should be
able to be much closer to allowing the
programmer to focus on the functionality
of their programs rather than how to
enforce the policies across all this and
so all the people who are working on it
at the current moment are these people
so there's me there's my advisor Armando
salar
zama there's Travis who's a master
student he's working on the the Python
implementation there's been who was
working on Scala web apps and now he's
working on Python web apps and also for
the faceted semantics we collaborated
with Cormac Flanagan and and his student
Tom Austin at UC Santa Cruz and they had
an initial non-policy or they had
initial faceted semantics that did not
have to do with solving for the labels
so in this talk I have described a
mechanism for automatically enforcing
privacy policies that's based on this
idea of having multiple views of all of
our values of interest and then relying
on the run time to handle these views so
that the appropriate result is shown
based on who's looking at it and also
who has written it I've described a
semantics for a language that does this
as well as some guarantees and some
experience we've had with an
implementation and some future
directions with handling inputs and with
interfacing with the database and I'd
like to leave off by saying that it's
really exciting I think that language
technology has brought us to a point
where we can think about automating
different concerns that are as global as
information flow and what I would like
to think about with all of you because
I'm here for the rest of the week is
what other applications we can have for
something like this and also potentially
what other program aspects we can think
about automating in this way so thanks
for coming and I'll take questions
a question about I love the abstraction
of the passive sort of sensitive values
so is there a way to understand that as
a sort of by translation to a sort of
standard system of information for you
know where values are just high or low
and you don't have the sort of
combination of the two right so that's a
that's a good question and I think that
um for there's there's a difference
between this and standard systems
because in standard systems for
information flow the idea is that you
stop programs that are leaking too much
information and so there's not this idea
if there's an alternate execution for or
there's an alternate way to produce a
result for those programs and so um if
that makes sense I'm thinking that your
faceted Bollywood sort of like a pair I
wonder you could encode your faceted
value is a pair in a conventional
information flow system where you know
one half is high another half is low
right so uh you could do that except I'm
we found that often you you should write
these programs to handle the fact that
you your low value might be flowing
through for instance um you might want
to use an option type instead of a
regular value when you're when you're
doing something or you might need to
handle default values in a certain way
so so from a programming perspective um
you don't want to just take existing
programs and put two values through if
that makes sense but um but I think what
you might be asking though is um if it i
guess if these guarantees map on to a
more traditional program is you don't
want the abstraction i answered you want
to hide the obscure you know abstract
away from the fact that it's a pair but
i'm wondering it just semantically we
can think about it as a transit you know
say your language and translate it to a
conventional one where you're passing
around these pairs everywhere so there's
all the boilerplate the semantics
introduce instant to do a sec i see so i
think a key difference with those also
is that um what what your high and low
label is also can depend on your actual
program value and I think that
dependence is not captured to my
knowledge
from so so conventionally your labels
are just higher low and they're a
concrete value right and they don't have
to do it the program but in our system
you can have these kind of weird
dependencies of the of the policy on the
program that I think is not
traditionally expressed in those
information flow systems yeah right
right we have dependent labels
essentially yeah the programmer does
have to be aware that their programming
in this system because the types of the
values are probably going to change yes
um right yes so the so we found that you
do want to program in a slightly
different way because you have to think
about okay I might have a default value
flowing through and the case of the
battleship example it was sort of a
wacky thing like you wouldn't program a
game in this separated way normally and
so it's a different way of implementing
right so yes I can see the result you
might move from like values to ranges of
values for some things right sometimes
you're just bomb out and have an option
right and you can also imagine I guess
having a data tape where you have
different levels of granularity like
this is my most fine-grained version
this is the next level of granularity
and this is my most most secret private
version or something like that and there
I think they're interesting programming
questions the kind of weak and values to
adhere to the policy you have to break
kind of obvious normal invariants that
will be associated with those types like
I mean if I've got some state right then
maybe good i get i get a sort of faked
up low version because i didn't want to
reveal this thing but but then I they
either you're kind of building some
shadow you know shadow file system so
for example you know the thing says it
needs access to the file system and I
want to deny that but then maybe rights
to the file system kind of appear to
work but then when I read I don't see
the consistent thing unless you spin up
a whole kind of parallel universe right
right yes I think there's a there's
there's some interesting programming
idiom questions to be answered there i'm
especially with with the right stuff
that we're looking at now I'm
you know if you wrote to the system but
actually you know no one no one is
seeing it should you know should
something else be happening should we
bundle these rights in some way so that
we can communicate that hey this weird
thing is happening but yeah there's this
is a space of questions that were we're
actively looking at if you want to talk
more i'm happy to talk about yet you to
run the full smc solver component every
time a new channel i guess up a
challenge created uh so right right now
we do um but i think there are ways to
cash this and that sort of thing and do
you think you could kind of module is do
you think that this framework needs to
pervade the full application it could be
so much isolated in the sense that you I
think about applying this to facebook
I'm sure they have millions of lines of
code in many different languages right
so so it seems cumbersome to apply
something like this to the entire code
base but your example the databases seem
to indicate that it may be difficult to
isolate what so I think I guess if there
are isolated data or you can isolate it
in a like like a strongly connected data
component you know like if this data
only depends on each other then we can
isolate this there but if you have
different parts of the system touching
the same data than you really want your
policies to pervade through that whole
thing and in that case I don't think you
should isolate it and I also think that
a lot of bugs in systems come from
having a having these policies break out
the boundaries of these things and so I
think you should really yeah for for
data that depends on each other it
should really you should be looking at
this across that whole whole part of the
system so you've got yeah and if you do
nest from do you do any text for like
unreachable ax t because the policy
might mean one of the values contact
you ever get there because see the outer
policy requires you to go to right hand
side let me enter one only of all let
you go left if you've gone because of
what policies seems you ever Ross well I
see yeah that's a that's a good point so
you can nos the facet and we don't do
any analysis right now for unreachable
ax t but I think that would be a good
way to sanity check this is some like
hey did you really mean this policy so
yeah that's a process uh we didn't ask
for any of these examples but um I guess
another another thing to point out is
that in the evaluation what you get as a
result is usually untested a nest and
facet tree where you have different
facet values that God combined well so
so you were saying that the this
equality were loading was essentially
the trick to hype pairs so that inside
the renter major language tab as new
operator overloading would be possible
basically just to do a sorceress austere
information like email discuss right so
so essentially for Python we had to
start doing a sorts transform because
you can't overload and an or which is
pretty important yeah so so you can
ensue yeah you can't do it with a source
transform Germany nay talents eventually
what's the runtime overhead of colleen's
it three every time you do print um so
the runtime of calling z3 is actually
pretty low so on what we did in our
Scala implementation was that we
evaluated things pretty much all the way
we did a full simplification pass and so
xiii was only called to resolve the
label values which is I'm and then we're
only defining bullion's and assigning
like or having a pretty small constraint
environment it was always like
milliseconds or something like that yeah
so so we weren't using XIII in any
significant way at all and in fact I'm
before we added the simplifications the
bottleneck and our previous approach was
the the communication with XIII and not
the z3 solving time
do you have thoughts on side-channel
attacks um so we haven't looked at that
very carefully but right now an
interesting thing is i guess i am for in
terms of timing you I'm since you're
executing everything you don't really
infer stuff about the private value
because you you do both sides and so in
that way that sort of obfuscates some
timing issues and also for for
termination I'm you're executing both
branches and so if some branch doesn't
terminate your whole thing is not going
to terminate so so I guess that's that's
our current understanding of it but but
I think especially as we look at some
optimizations and we drop branches and
things like that we're going to need to
look at side channels more carefully
this is a funny thing because during the
security push sort of post security push
to his way back from said threes a
Pottle teasing for being developed we
got away we didn't have to go through
security review of Zeb 3 and now it's
kind of nightmare because males m3 is
apparently quite crucial to you yeah
yeah so we'll keep that in mind when we
just I don't have it to keep XIII in our
system thanks